Errol Morris: You asked me about
the nature of our relationship.
John le Carré: I needed to know
who I was talking to.
Were you my friend across the fire?
Who are you?
Errol Morris: And if I can't answer
that question?
♪
John le Carré: It's terribly difficult
to recruit for a secret service.
You're looking for somebody
who's a bit bad,
but at the same time, loyal.
There's a type.
And I fit it perfectly.
♪
Errol Morris: In your memoir you say,
"None of it's true.
It's as I imagined it."
John le Carré: When I was in MI-6,
it wasn't enough for me.
So, what I did was
reinvent the secret world,
and fill my own people with it.
♪
Errol Morris: Why is betrayal
an important concept to you?
John le Carré:
It has a long family background.
Writing is a journey of self-discovery.
I see my own life as a succession
of embraces and escapes.
(Music intensifies)
(Gunshot)
Errol Morris:
Maybe this is an interrogation.
Maybe I am self-deceived.
I don't know.
But I'll answer any question
you wish me to answer,
as truthfully as I can.
♪